[Music]
heating homes is heating the planet
we're emitting more and more carbon
right now we're going in exactly the
wrong direction three quarters of fossil
fuels used in the world's buildings goes
on heating
i do not believe that you just sit back
and wait for something to happen that's
not good enough
[Music]
in 2021 missions grew at the fastest
rate for many years
i've got a massive carbon footprint so
reducing reusing is my vibe at the
moment
so what's the best way to keep warm
without warming the planet
[Music]
thirty-seven-year-old mcquenna is a
businessman living in johannesburg
his homecome office is powered by
electricity from the national grid but
for the past few years south africa has
failed to produce enough electricity and
so power cuts have become the norm you'd
get home from work literally put the key
in the door open up and then the power
would go out now you can't cook so what
now now you can't watch a tv you can't
zoom your friends or whatever it is
mukwena also uses the electricity to
power a hot water boiler currently we
can only take a shower in the morning so
if i go out for a jog somewhere or go
hiking or whatever it is i'd have to get
back home switch on the water heater
wait 20 minutes draw electricity just so
i can have a shower
this uncertainty around power has pushed
mcquenna to consider going off grid and
disconnect entirely from the national
electricity supply and he has a personal
motivation for doing this too
i have a background in motor sales one
of my biggest motivations is basically
just trying to undo all the v8s that
i've sold
i've got a massive carbon footprint
i'm trying to just live a more
sustainable existence
just trying to do my bet
in 2020 only 7.6 of south africa's
electricity came from renewable sources
and almost 90 percent came from coal
mukwona is keen to find a more
sustainable solution so he's no longer
adding to his country's carbon footprint
so i came across
basically two ways to heat the water
it's either through gas or through solar
gas is still a fossil fuel at the end of
the day to get gas is still not a
sustainable way to
live
so solas seems the easiest most
sustainable option to solve your water
heating problems
in a country which averages 2
500 hours of sunshine a year that makes
a lot of sense the gloomier skies cool
for more inventive solutions
five thousand pounds to scrap your old
boiler and make your home greener with a
heat pump in britain the government is
wrestling with the same challenge as
mokwena of heating homes without burning
fossil fuels
green is good
green is right
green works
britain uses more energy for heating
than to power the electricity grid or
run its transport system and seventy
percent of it comes from burning natural
gas producing more than a quarter of the
country's co2 emissions
part of the strategy is to try to get us
all eventually doing this having heat
pumps that don't use fossil fuels
installed in place of gas boilers no one
is being told to rip out their boiler
let's be clear about that angela had to
cover the initial cost of her heat pump
heat pumps
heat pumps heat pump heat pump heat pump
heat pumps heat pump heat pumps so what
is a heat pump
a heat pump is a bit like a refrigerator
but doing the opposite because in your
refrigerator at home you're extracting
the the warmth from inside the fridge
and you're pumping it outside so you
notice that there's a little bit of warm
air around the outside of your
refrigerator a heat pump does exactly
the same thing it sucks out small
amounts of heat from the air around your
house and it concentrates it and pumps
it into your house to make you warm so
it's a really efficient way of
extracting what is essentially free heat
from the world around you concentrating
it and bring it into your home
[Music]
this is max fordham a pioneer of
sustainable design and environmentally
friendly engineering
today his company is a leading voice in
the push towards low energy buildings
with low or net zero carbon emissions
and this is one of its latest projects
transforming oxford university's wolfson
college with a heat pump powered heating
system
senior partner bill watts has the job of
bringing the vision to life somehow
there you go
the heat pump it's an air source heat
pump there are four of them they're
about five meters long um
that high and they're going to be
sitting here
four big fans one two three four
uh sucking around in at the back and
then blowing it
out that way
and this basement is about to become the
engine room for bill's mission to reduce
the carbon footprint of the college
these are the boilers that he the
building currently we've got about 2
500 kilowatts
of boilerpower
and we're replacing it with 750
kilowatts of heat pump
we're confident that we've dropped the
amount of heat loss of the building so
we can reduce the size of the heating
system
by
to a third of what it is
nearly 20 million heat pumps were sold
worldwide in 2019 a number that needs to
triple if climate targets are to be
reached but those targets are also
dependent on a more traditional approach
to keeping buildings warm
okay so this
is a new window
we've got the triple
triple glazing the insulation of this
glass is a factor of 10 better compared
to single glazing and it's absolutely
amazing it's exciting stuff for an
environmental engineer his clients on
the other hand are likely to be more
excited by the 80 cut in the college's
energy bills that this extra insulation
is going to help deliver
take out the old window put the damp
proof membrane down put in a new window
foam it up seal it up
and then
insulate around
that's basically it
back in south africa mokwena has reached
similar conclusions to bill watts
so for insulation in the ceiling i would
put pink foam to help insulate in the
south african context just to keep the
heat out more than to keep it in
then definitely change the windows
but every day consumers like mcquenna
don't have the deep pockets of an oxford
university college
cost is a problem when it comes to
double glazed glass it just means
remodeling again and it's it's a huge
cost
what we're doing is we're asking the
government to insulate all the uk homes
in britain insulation and its sometimes
prohibitive cost has become a
surprisingly hot topic
there's nothing more important than
insulating people's homes and making a
start on cutting the emissions
but poor insulation isn't the only
obstacle facing heat pump advocates up
to 13 million homes in the uk that
currently use natural gas for heating
will not be suitable for a heat pump
many because they simply wouldn't have
space little surprise then the energy
with which other carbon-free heating
solutions are being pursued
from solar to wood-burning biomass
boilers to one potential fuel of the
future still trying to escape its past
the hindenburg's 7 million cubic feet of
hydrogen gas had ignited
this historic disaster hung over public
attitudes to hydrogen use for decades
even though it wasn't the gas that
caused the explosion
the reflexive fear of hydrogen even has
a name
the hindenburg syndrome
but that's begun to change
from food to medicine this machine could
change all that hydrogen has been used
for years in industry
and is now a potential clean fuel of the
future for trucks for planes
ships and trains
so why not houses too
here in a quiet corner of northern
england hydrogen is being domesticated
this unassuming house runs on 100
hydrogen for domestic heating and
cooking since 2016 we have been looking
at ways in which the existing
infrastructure of 280 000 kilometers of
distribution pipework could be
repurposed using a carbon-free method of
heating and cooking the idea was to
demonstrate that hydrogen is a plausible
way forward in reducing the cow
emissions in the uk
in this test project there are no direct
carbon emissions at all but the hydrogen
fuel itself needs to be produced a
process which requires a lot of
electricity and is currently done using
fossil fuels so its backers are on the
lookout for sustainable sources that
might just be going spare
when you've got low demand for
electricity they actually stop the wind
turbines running because they don't need
them
whereas they could actually run them and
that could generate the green
electricity to produce hydrogen
northern gas hopes to have hydrogen in
uk homes by the end of the decade and if
hydrogen can be produced using
sustainable energy then it can be a
truly green fuel but that's a big if
the climate crisis my friends is the
test of our times
if heating homes is to stop heating the
planet government and industry will need
to work together to bring green energy
solutions to a tipping point
by saying the industry will provide and
make it all nice and cheap is true but
they need certainty that that is going
to happen
the levers of state need to be brought
to bear and say
this particular fuel source is going to
be banned by this date and then
everybody gets behind it
and only government can do that
for the millions like mo who want to do
the right thing and go green
they need support now to make their
journey to a green future possible that
migration
from
grid energy to renewable energy
it's not as achievable as i'd like it to
be it's not so easy to get there
but
we try
[Music]
i'm jon fassman the economist u.s
digital editor to keep up with all our
climate change coverage click the link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe